ASSEMBLY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
HEARING CALLING FOR MEMBERS THIS
IS THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE IN ROOM.
FOUR FOUR SEVEN SERGEANTS PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS -- WE'LL
GET STARTED AS A SUB -- SO THIS
IS OUR FIRST LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMITTEE JUST A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS TO GO BEFORE
WE START.
WE HAVE THIRTEEN ITEMS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY THE CONSENT
CALENDAR INCLUDES THE FOLLOWING
ITEMS.
ITEM NUMBER TWO SB TWO FOUR TWO
ROTH ITEM NUMBER THREE SB TWO
EIGHT SEVEN NIELSEN.
ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB TWO NINE
FIVE MCGUIRE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE SB THREE TO
FOUR RUBIO.
ITEMS SIX SEVEN AND EIGHT SB
THREE EIGHTY THREE EIGHTY ONE
AND THREE TO BY THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENT AND FINANCE.
ITEM ELEVEN SB FIVE NINE EIGHT
MORLOCK.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB SIX FOUR
SIX MORALE.
ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN SB SEVEN
FIVE ONE IS THAT RIGHT RUBIO --
AND ONCE WE GET A QUORUM WILL
ENTERTAIN THAT CONSENT -- WE
WILL CORRECT THAT ITEMS NUMBER
SIX SEVEN EIGHT OUR ITEM -- SB.
THREE SEVENTY NINE THREE EIGHTY
AND THREE EIGHTY ONE WHICH ARE
THE GOVERNMENT FINANCE COMMITTEE.
OF BILLS.
OKAY WITH THAT -- I'D LIKE TO
WELCOME UP.
A SENATOR GLACIER ITEM NUMBER
TEN SB FIVE THIRTY ONE IN
WELCOME MISTER BLASIER SENATOR
GLAZERS THIS WEEK.
THANK YOU THANK YOU -- MADAM
CHAIR FOR SHOULD THE TIME THIS
MORNING THIS AFTERNOON -- THE
BILL IN FRONT OF YOU -- SEEKS TO
STOP A PERVERSE INCENTIVE IN OUR
TAX CODE.
THAT HAS LED LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO GIVE AWAY.
BILLIONS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
TAX REVENUE TO PRIVATE COMPANIES.
THESE DEALS TAKE MONEY FROM
EVERY CITY IN THE STATE.
AND THEY GIVE IT TO SOME OF THE
RICHEST CORPORATIONS IN THE
WORLD AND IT'S JUST NOT RIGHT.
UNDER THE BRADLEY BURNS UNIFORM
LOCAL SALES TAX LOST SALES TAX
REVENUE IS ALLOCATED TO THE
POINT OF SALE.
NOW FOR BRICK AND MORTAR STORES
THIS MEANS ALLOCATING THE
REVENUE TO THE JURISDICTION IN
WHICH THE STORES LOCATED PRETTY
CLEAR.
BUT ONLINE RETAILERS AND WE ALL
KNOW HOW.
MORE AND MORE THAT -- FOLKS
REASON ONLINE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO CHOOSE WHERE THEY ALLOCATE
SALES TAX REVENUE.
THAT COULD BE A WAREHOUSE IT
COULD BE A DISTRIBUTION CENTER
IT COULD EVEN BE A SALES OFFICE.
THIS ALLOWS COMPANIES TO DIRECT
REVENUE TO A SINGLE JURISDICTION
IN THE STATE.
NOW COMPANIES USE THIS AS
LEVERAGE WHEN NEGOTIATING WITH
THE LOCATE AND A CERTAIN PLACE
IN THE STATE.
AND THE RESULT OF THAT MY
FRIENDS IS IS BEEN A RIG PROCESS --
DRIVING CITIES TO ACCEPT
INCREASINGLY.
ONEROUS TAX SHARING AGREEMENTS
IN EXCANGE FOR ONLINE RETAILERS
BUILDING.
OR RELOCATING IN THEIR
JURISDICTION.
UNDER THESE AGREEMENTS.
I THE COMPANY'S PROFIT BOTH FROM
THEIR ONLINE SALES AND FROM THE
SALES TAX REBATES.
OFTEN CITIES WILL GIVE THESE
COMPANIES MORE THAN HALF OF THE
SALES TAX REVENUE.
ALLOCATED TO THEIR JURISDICTION.
HE'S COMPANIES BENEFIT AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE PUBLIC.
AT A TIME WHEN CITIES ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND PUBLIC
PROGRAMS COMPANIES ARE SAFELY
SIPHONING BILLIONS IN TAXPAYER
DOLLARS TO THESE AGREEMENTS.
FURTHER WHILE THESE DEALS ARE
OFTEN TOUTED FOR CREATING JOBS
AND HAVING SUBSTANTIAL ECONOMIC
BENEFITS.
IN MY VIEW THESE CLAIMS ARE
DUBIOUS.
SOME OF THESE AGREEMENTS DO NOT
REQUIRE THAT THE PROMISED JOBS
OR EVEN CREATED AND EVEN WHEN
THEY DO.
HIS JOBS CAN BE AN AND WAREHOUSE
FACILITIES WHAT WHERE THE WORK
IS GRUELING LOW WAGE AND LACK
BENEFITS.
SO THESE CITIES AT THAT DO THESE
DEALS THEY DO NEED REAL JOB
OPPORTUNITIES FOR WORKING
FAMILIES BUT WE DON'T NEED A
RACE TO THE BOTTOM WHICH IS THE
CURRENT SITUATION. FOR THOSE
REASONS THE MEASURE THAT'S
BEFORE YOU WOULD PROHIBIT ANY
FUTURE SALES TAX SHARING
AGREEMENTS.
BETWEEN LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
PRIVATE COMPANIES IT HAS NO
EFFECT ON ANY EXISTING.
AGREEMENTS.
IT TAKES NO MONEY FROM ANY CITY.
UNDER THIS BILL.
BUT IT IS NOT AT AND IT DOES NOT
REDUCE THE SALES TAX REVENUE TO
ANY CITY CAN RECEIVE IN THE
FUTURE.
THEBILL HAS BROAD SUPPORT FROM --
WIDE RANGE OF FOLKS FROM THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES WHICH WE HEAR
IT FROM THE JUST A MOMENT.
THE LABOR FEDERATION AND A
VARIETY OF OTHER CITIES WHEN YOU
DIG DOWN DEEP ON THIS ISSUE FIND
THAT -- IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF
5% OR SO OF THE CITIES ARE
MAKING THESE DEALS AND 95%.
CITIES RICH AND POOR COASTAL IN
LINE EVERYBODY ELSE HAS BEEN A
LOSER.
AT ALL WE'RE SAYING IN THIS BILL
IS LET'S NOT MAKE IT WORSE WE
HAVE TO LOOK AT THE WHOLE TAX
CODE AND HOW THESE THINGS ARE
HANDLED.
BUT LET'S STOP THE BLEEDING --
IN THIS RACE TO THE BOTTOM WITH
THAT HAPPY TO INTRODUCE DâN
KERA REPRESENTING THE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES THANK YOU BOTH
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- BIRDS -- DECKER
COULD BE HELPFUL YOU CALIFORNIA
CITIES OF THE LEAGUE TARTED
TALKING ABOUT THIS THIS ISSUE IN
TERMS OF THE EFFECTS OF YOU
COMMERCE ON WERE ON LOCAL
REVENUES INCLUDING SALES TAXES
GOING BACK ALL THE WAY TO A
TWENTY FIFTEEN HAVE HAD A NUMBER
OF INTERNAL WORKING GROUPS AND
OTHER.
OTHER THINGS -- THIS THIS BILL
IS SOMETHING IS POLICY THAT THAT --
THIS THIS RECOMMENDATION NUMBERS
FROM THAT PROCESS.
WE ARE AS MOST OF THE FOLKS IN
THE ROOM NO ARE STAUNCH DEFENDER
OF LOCAL AUTHORITY INCLUDING THE
AUTHORITY OF OUR COMMUNITIES TO
ENGAGE IN ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT
AND WE COULD CONTINUE TO DO SO.
THE CHALLENGE HERE WITH THIS
ISSUE AND THE REASON THE LEGAL
SUPPORTING IT IS SOME OF THESE
AGREEMENTS REALLY HAVE THE
EFFECT OF OF THE COMMUNITIES
THAT REALLY REBUILDING ITS OWN
REVENUE AS PART OF A ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT -- INCENTIVE IT'S
REPEATING EVERYBODY ELSE'S
REVENUE AND THAT'S KIND OF WERE
FROM A LEGAL STANDPOINT.
WE WE THINK THAT THAT IT'S GOOD
POLICY TO TO LIMIT THESE -- AND
PROHIBIT THESE DEALS GOING
FORWARD -- BUT AS THE AS THE
SENATOR SAID IT DOESN'T AFFECT
ANY EXISTING AGREEMENTS IT
DOESN'T UNDERMINE THE ABILITY OF
A LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO USE THEIR
OWN RESOURCES TO TO GIVE
ECONOMIC INCENTIVES.
AND JOB WE WE THINK IT'S GOOD
POLICY GOING FORWARD ESPECIALLY
IN THE EVER EXPANDING -- ECONOMY
IF HE COMMERCE -- AND WE WOULD
URGE YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR OTHER
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THEIR FLOCKS
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION ALSO
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE -- ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
GOOD AFTERNOON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME'S ANGIE MINETTI
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF
FRESNO RESPECTFULLY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE.
ALTHOUGH SB FIVE THIRTY ONE DOES
GRANDFATHER IN EXISTING
INCENTIVE AGREEMENTS --
ELIMINATING THE PROSPECT OF LEE
REMAINS THE VERY VITAL ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TOOL THAT HAS BEEN
PIVOTAL IN GRAB JOB CREATION
LOCALLY.
I FRESNO FEELS VERY STRONGLY
ABOUT THIS MEASURE I'M WITH THE
INCENTIVE AGREEMENTS THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO STRIKE WE'VE
ATTRACTED BUSINESS AWAY FROM
ARIZONA WITH ONE OF OUR IN --
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS ALSO HAVE
SECURED THIRTY FIVE HUNDRED JOBS
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY I'M WITH
HUNDREDS MORE INDIRECT JOBS --
STEMMING FROM THESE INCENTIVE
AGREEMENTS -- YOU KNOW DE THE
INCENTIVES ARE ALL JOB CREATION
BASED THE IF THE JOBS ARE
CREATED THE INCENTIVES ARE NOT
THERE FOR THE RETAILER AND SAY
IT YOU KNOW FROM A TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY PERSPECTIVE
WE BELIEVE THAT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO INCLUDE IN THESE AGREEMENTS
WHICH IS WHY WE HAVE.
YOU KNOW FULL DISCLOSURE FULL
HEARINGS ON THESE TOPICS -- YOU
KNOW WE ARE.
AS AS A CENTER HAD MENTIONED
THIS IS GETTING OUT THE SITE IS
OF A SITE IS ALLOCATION ISSUE
AND MEMBERS IF YOU'LL INDULGE ME
FOR A MOMENT -- IF MY PINEAPPLE
BLAZER THAT I'M WEARING RIGHT
NOW IS NOT AVAILABLE IN THE CITY
OF SACRAMENTO AND I GO TO SAN
FRANCISCO TO PURCHASE IT.
SACRAMENTO ISN'T GOING AFTER SAN
FRANCISCO FOR THAT RAVENEL.
ALL OF THAT REVENUE IS GOING TO
SAN FRANCISCO WHERE THOSE JOBS
ARE WHERE THE POINT OF SALE WAS
WHERE THAT WORK WAS DONE WE
WOULD DISPUTE THE SAME. FOR
FRESNO IF THERE ARE ORDERS
FILLED AND PACKAGES ARE
FULFILLED IN OUR DISTRICT AND
JOBS ARE THERE AND THAT'S WHERE
THE WORKERS ARE PUTTING IN THE
LABOR.
AND THE WORK WE WOULD DISPUTE
THAT THAT'S WHERE THE REVENUE
SHOULD -- SHOULD GO NOW AGAIN WE
BELIEVE THIS WARRANTS A MUCH
LARGER CONVERSATION AND RIGHT
NOW THIS BILL IS TAKING ONE
ASPECT OF OUR TAX LAW.
AND TAKING AWAY AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TOOL THAT IS
FREQUENTLY USED BY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES.
I'M THIS BILL SIMON'S OUR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE FRESNO
OUT OF POVERTY AND CAN AND AND
THAT'S WHY WE ARE OPPOSED THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU SO MUCH MUCH AUDIBLE GOV ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF PARIS.
NOT SURE OF ANY OF YOU KNOW
WHERE THE CITY OF PARIS'S IT'S A
VERY THANK YOU IT'S A VERY FLAT
DUSTY LITTLE LAND THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF RESOURCES THERE.
AND I LOVE IT I MEAN I PEOPLE
LIVE THERE RIGHT AND SO THE IT
SO HOME TO A LOT OF PEOPLE BUT
IT'S NOT -- COASTAL IT'S NOT YOU
KNOW IT'S JUST IT HAS THE
RESOURCES THAT HAS IN THOSE ARE
VERY LIMITED AT THIS POINT.
THEY'VE HAD GENERATIONAL POVERTY
AND THESE TAX TURN AGREEMENTS
HAVE ALLOWED THEM TO SLOWLY
CRAWL OUT OF THAT.
JUST A QUICK STOP FROM THE CITY
OF PARIS IN TWENTY THIRTEEN
THEIR UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WAS 16%.
DIRECTLY RELATED TO THESE TAX
AND AGREEMENTS THEIR
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE HAS DROPPED TO
SIX POINT 7% AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE JOBS I KNOW PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THESE ARE.
POOR PAYING JOBS IN THE CITY OF
PARIS AND I CAN ONLY SPEAK FOR
OUR COMMUNITY AND FOR OUR
TEXTURE IN AGREEMENTS THE WAGES
THAT ARE WORKERS ARE PAID ARE UP.
TO BETWEEN FIFTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR TO TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS AN
HOUR FOR NON MANAGEMENT
POSITIONS AND IF YOU HAVE A
MANAGEMENT POSITION YOU HAVE
SIXTY SIX THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR WHICH IS.
A HUGE INCREASE FOR THE MEDIAN
INCOME IN THE CITY OF PARIS I
THINK THE AND I I DO BELIEVE
THAT YOU THE THE AUTHOR IS
TRYING TO HAVE A VERY.
THOUGHTFUL CONVERSATION HOWEVER
I THINK THERE ARE BIG PIECES OF
THIS THAT ARE MISSING THE CITY
OF PARIS DOES NOT HAVE ANY OTHER
IT WOULD HAVE TRIED IT HAS TRIED.
IT HAS BEEN TRYING TO GET AN IN
AND OUT TO COME INTO THE CITY
FOR FOUR YEARS WE HAVE FINE
DINING THE CONSIST OF DENNY'S.
I HOP SIZZLER IN PORKY'S I DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT WAS UNTIL I
WENT TO PARIS.
IT IT THESE TEXTURED AGREEMENTS
HAVE ALLOWED AN INCREMENTAL
INCREASE IN THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR THESE PEOPLE THAT THEN
ALLOWS THEM TO HAVE
DISCRETIONARY INCOME BECAUSE
BEFORE THEY HAD NONE THEY WERE
PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK.
AND THAT'SWHEN RETAILERS WANT
TO COME INTO YOUR TOWN WHEN THEY
SEE THAT YOU HAVE AN INCREASE IN
YOUR MEDIUM CUP WHEN YOU SEE
THAT YOUR RESIDENTS.
CAN.
PAY THE TEN DOLLARS FOR
HAMBURGER IN AND OUT OTHER THAN
THAT THERE HAS BEEN.
A DEARTH OF CORPORATIONS AND
RETAILERS AND SERVICES THAT WANT
TO COME INTO THE CITY OF PARIS
BECAUSE WE DON'T HAVE.
ANY OTHER ECONOMIC TOOL TO
INCENTIVIZE THEM TO COME THIS IS.
LITERALLY ONE OF THEIR SINGULAR
TOLD AND I APPRECIATE THAT
THERE'S BEEN A CONVERSATION IN
THIS BUILDING PARTICULAR ABOUT
POSSIBLY HAVING REDEVELOPMENT.
RESURFACE WHICH WOULD BE AMAZING
WE WOULD SUPPORT THAT WE DO
SUPPORT THAT BUT IF ANYONE READS
THE PAPER IF ANYONE TRACKS
GOVERNOR SOME COMMENTS.
HE'S NOT FOR THAT AT LEAST NOT
RIGHT NOW AND SO TO OFFER A
SPECULATIVE TOOL FOR THEM.
AND TAKING AWAY A LEGITIMATE
TOOL.
WE REALLY WOULD WE WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE A MORE THOUGHTFUL
CONVERSATION ABOUT LET'S LOOK AT
EVERYTHING BUT THIS TOOL RIGHT
NOW. TO BE REMOVED WITHOUT BACK
FILLING IN SOME WAY.
IS GOING TO HURT.
THE RESIDENTS OF PARIS.
EVEN KEEPING THEIR CURRENT
AGREEMENTS BECAUSE YOU'VE JUST
PUT A CEILING OVER US AND YOU'VE
JUST SAID.
GREAT WE'RE GRABBED THE YOU HAD
EXCELLENT GROWTH DON'T EXPECT TO
GROW ANYMORE.
AND FOR THAT WE WOULD ASK THAT
YOU OPPOSE AB S. I'M SORRY SB.
FIVE THIRTY ONE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ARE THERE OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
SEEING NONE OTHER ANY QUESTIONS
OF THE COMMITTEE ON BEFORE.
YES.
BUT THAT IS ME SOMEONE VOEPEL.
A QUESTION AND ALSO A COMMENT.
QUESTION FIRST.
I'D.
IN OPPOSITION TO THIS.
MAINLY BECAUSE I WAS MAYOR OF A
CITY OF SIXTY THOUSAND AND WE
MADE AN AGREEMENT WITH A MAJOR --
HOTEL SUPPLIER.
THEY HAD A WAREHOUSE OF ONE
PARTY CALIFORNIA BUT THEY WANTED
TO CALL CENTER IN OUR CITY.
OKAY SO THAT'S ANOTHER THING
THAT THIS BILL.
I'M NOT SEEING HOW IT WOULD HELP.
THE CITY LIKE.
NINE THE CALL CENTER.
IS IN OUR ZIP CODE.
AND WE GET ALL THAT SALES TAX.
EVEN THOUGH THE WAREHOUSES IN
ANOTHER PART OF THE STATE SO.
THAT'S A INTERESTING DICHOTOMY
THERE -- MY QUESTION IS WOULD
THE AUTHOR BE WILLING.
TO AMEND.
THIS TO CITIES.
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
POPULATION ARE HIGHER.
THAT WAY THE YOUNGER SMALLER
CITIES HAVE A CHANCE TO COMPETE.
FOR CALL CENTERS WHERE HOUSES
EXCEPT A BECAUSE THEY NEED TO
WAVE MORE THAN SAN FRANCISCO LA
OR SAN DIEGO [inaudible]
SO.
THAT'S MY QUESTION.
WOULD IT BE POSSIBLE TO PUT A
LIMIT POPULATION LIMIT.
ON THE BILL.
OF THROUGH THE CHAIR -- WELL
THANK YOU FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
QUESTION AND I THINK THAT --
THIS IS A SLIPPERY SLOPE YOU GET
ON HERE WHEN YOU START TO PICK
WINNERS OR LOSERS OR ADVANCED
ONE GROUP AT COMMUNITY VERSUS
ANOTHER I THINK IF THE
OVERRIDING STATE GOAL IS
FAIRNESS.
IN OUR TAX SYSTEM FAIRNESS.
WHERE EVERYBODY HAS THE SAME
PLAYFIELD PLAYING FIELD IN WHICH?
TO DEAL I THINK THAT'S REALLY
WHAT WE'RE STRIVING FOR HERE AND
THAT I I RECOGNIZE THAT
COMMUNITIES.
AND THIS HAPPENS AND LOTS OF
DIFFERENT WAYS.
I IT COULD BECAUSE YOU HAVE --
MOUNTAINS ARE YOU HAVE A LAKE OR
YOUR NEXT TO THE BECAUSE THERE'S
ALL KINDS OF THINGS THAT MAKE.
LIFE AND COMMUNITIES LIVE IT IS
FAIR ENOUGH FAIR OR UNFAIR AND
SO.
I THINK THAT WENT ONCE YOU START
CREATING THESE CARVE OUTS.
LET'S JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THEIR
MANIPULATED BY OTHERS.
OTHER WORDS IT YOU START
CREATING THE CIRCUMSTANCES WERE
IT SPECIALIZE WILL THAT'S THE
THAT'S THE CAPITALIST SYSTEM
THEY'RE GOING TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO MANIPULATE THAT -- AND I ALL
I CAN SAY IS IS THAT WELL I AM
VERY SYMPATHETIC TO YOUR
SITUATION THE COMMUNITY IN WHICH
YOU COME FROM AS WELL AS THE
OTHERS THAT HAVE SPOKEN TO HER
TODAY -- THIS IS NOT A FOR IT WE
SHOULD USE OUR TAX CODE TO DO
THAT WHEN IT CAN BE SO
MANIPULATED BY OTHERS -- TO THE
DISADVANTAGE PUBLIC THE PUT THE
PUBLIC GOOD AND THE PUBLIC GOOD
IS A FAIR TAX SYSTEM WHERE THE
IMPACTS.
OF THOSE -- THAT COME FROM THOSE
ENTERPRISES ARE ARE COVERED IN
SOME FASHION.
AND SO WHILE YOU TALK ABOUT THE
CALL CENTER GETTING THE REVENUE
BECAUSE IS DESIGNATED AT THE
POINT OF SALE.
THAT DISTRIBUTION FACILITY OR
THAT MANUFACTURING FACILITY THAT
HAS ALL THE TRUCK TRAFFIC AND
MAYBE EVEN THE POLLUTION THEY'RE
VERY IN ALL THE BIRDS.
THE MANIPULATION IS THAT YOU
HAVE THE AT THAT CITY YOU
RECOGNIZE GETS THE BENEFIT
BECAUSE THEY GET THE CALL CENTER
THEIR DESIGNATING AS POINT OF
SALE.
THAT'S A MANIPULATION OF THE
COAT IT'S NOT ABOUT WHERE
IMPACTS HAPPEN AND YES IT DOES --
IT CAN'T HURT SMALLER
COMMUNITIES BUT YOU COULD ALSO
ARGUE THAT.
THOSE ARE THE TYPE OF
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE THE LOWER
TAX BASE -- THAT HAVE A MORE
RESPONSIVE SAID.
A COMMUNITY LESS REGULATION.
SO THERE'S LOTS OF THINGS TO TRY.
TO ALLOW PEOPLE TO MAKE THOSE
CHOICES CITIES CAN AND ENGAGE IN
THE WAY THEY THINK THEY CAN MAKE
THEM COMPETITIVE BUT HERE'S THE
THING.
THEY CAN.
CREATE INCENTIVES.
THEY CAN USE THE BRADLEY BURNS
SALES TAX EVEN UNDER THIS
MEASURE TO CREATE INCENTIVES BUT
THE DIFFERENCE IS THEY HAVE TO
USE THEIR BRADLEY BIRDS.
NOT EVERYBODY ELSE'S CITIES
BRADLEY BURNS WHICH IS THE
MANIPULATION TODAY SO THEY CAN.
PUT THAT WELCOME THAT OUT IN
pUSING THE TAX CODE THAT THEY THE
MONEY THEY GET BUT IT'S THE
MINUTE ELATION THAT I'M TRYING
TO DO WITH THE IN THE BILL.
RESPECTFULLY WERE LESS COMMON.
ONE LAST COMMENT ON NOW -- AND
THEN I'LL BE QUIET.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
COMMAND CONTROL [inaudible]
AND SUPPRESSING.
COMMERCE.
AND FREE ENTERPRISE AND PEOPLE
THAT ARE WILLING. TO ACCEPT LESS
TAXES FROM AN ENTITY IN ORDER TO
GET.
AN INCREMENT OF THE TAXES.
SO WHAT I WOULD SAY IS.
IF I'M IN A SMALL CITY THAT'S
WILLING TO GIVE UP HALF THE
SALES TAX. TO GET THAT ENTITY.
WELL THEN WHERE EVER THEY WERE
TO BEGIN WITH HAD BETTER CUT A
DEAL TO THAT'S CALLED
COMPETITION THAT HELPS KEEP
PRICES LOW THAT HELPS THE JOBS.
IT IS CALLED FREE ENTERPRISE WHO
CAN MAKE THE BEST DEAL.
THAT'S NOT COMMAND CONTROL
SOCIALISTIC TYPE OF BUSINESS
VENEZUELA HAS COMMAND CONTROL.
I LIKE TO SEE HEALTHY
COMPETITION I'M DONE.
YES -- ASSEMBLYMEMBER BURNER
HARLOT -- THINGS THAT ARE --
ACTUALLY MI SIX GREAT BUT IT
LIKE THAT [inaudible]
SO -- SORRY -- SO I DID MY SIX
GRAY FUNDAY BACK AND LIKE PARIS
BACK IN THE DAY I GREW UP IN THE
INLAND EMPIRE AND THERE ARE
COMMUNITIES.
IN OUR STATE -- THAT DON'T HAVE
RESOURCES SO COULD YOU ADDRESS
SOME OF THE CONCERNS BROUGHT UP
BY THE OPPOSITION IN TERMS OF
COMMITTEES THAT DON'T HAVE
RESOURCES LIKE THE CITY OF PARIS.
IF THIS WAS TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM
WHAT OTHER OPTIONS DO YOU
ENVISION OR DO WE HAVE AVAILABLE --
IF THIS WERE REMOVED.
THROUGH THE CHAIR -- SO AT THIS
MEASURE ONLY STOPS NEW DEALS
FROM HAPPENING OKAY IT DOESN'T
CHANGE ANY OF THE EXISTING DEALS
THAT HAVE BEEN IN PLACE FOR TEN
OR TWENTY YEARS.
SO THE THE PUBLIC ENTITIES ARE
LOSING ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS
FROM THESE FEELS YEARLY.
OKAY ACCORDING TO A FINANCIAL
ANALYSIS THIS IS SAYS WE
SHOULDN'T ALLOW IT TO CONTINUE
TO HAPPEN.
I IN THE WAY IT'S HAPPENING.
THE THE DIFFICULTY IS THAT --
SHOULD WE BE USING THIS PART OF
THE TAX CODE TO TAKE MONEY FROM
THE 95% OF THE OTHER CITIES TO
HELP.
THAT THE A WHAT WOULD MAY BE
VIEWED AS DISADVANTAGED CITIES
THAT'S REALLY THE QUESTION AND
AND FOR ME THE ANSWER IS NO.
THAT THAT THIS PART OF THE TAX
CODE SHOULD NOT WE SHOULD NOT
ALLOW IT TO BE MANIPULATED
BECAUSE WHILE YOU MAY FEEL IT'S
HELPING THIS ONE DISADVANTAGED
CITY.
IT'S ONLY TAKING MONEY FROM 95%
OF THE OTHER CITIES.
IT'S ALLOWING THAT CORPORATION
TO GET THE MONEY BACK TO THEM IN
SOME CASES THESE DEALS GET A
100% OF THAT TAX RATE COMMENT
BACK TO THE COMPANY.
AND THEY SAY WE'RE DOING THAT
BECAUSE WE'RE GETTING THE JOBS
THESE -- THESE THAT THESE GREAT
WAREHOUSE JOBS -- SO LOOK I I
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THERE ARE THERE
ARE FOLKS THAT HAVE TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF IT AND WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO DO THAT UNDER UNDER THIS
BILL IF IT WERE TO BECOME LAW
BUT WE'RE NOT ON WINDING ANY
DEALS.
AND THEY STILL CAN USE THEIR
THEIR THEIR TAX SYSTEM INCLUDING
BRADLEY BURNS. TO PROVIDE
INCENTIVES -- FOR THOSE
COMPANIES TO LOCATE THERE THAT
DOESN'T NOT NOTHING HERE TAKES
THAT AWAY -- BUT I I I HAVE NO
GREAT SOLUTION TO A PRIVILEGE
THAT YOU KNOW AS A CITIES THAT
ARE THAT ARE STRUGGLING I I
DON'T THERE'S NO MAGIC BULLET
OUT THERE ANYWHERE.
AND CERTAINLY NOT IN THIS BILL
IT JUST SAYS YOU CAN'T MAKE
ANYMORE NEW DEALS TO TAKE THE
MONEY FROM 95% OF THE OTHER
CITIES.
THANK YOU YES AS SOME RIVAS --
SO THANK YOU -- FOR THAT
CLARIFICATION -- YOU KNOW I
APPRECIATE HEARING THE FACT THAT
YOU KNOW THIS IS NOT GONNA EXIST
THOSE T WON'T AFFECT THOSE
EXISTING CONTRACTS -- OR THOSE
AGREEMENTS BUT I APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORT I THINK THAT -- YOU KNOW
THIS THIS CERTAINLY ISN'T AN
ISSUE.
AND AND AND EASY ISSUE TO TACKLE
IT WAS VERY COMPLICATED.
BUT I THINK THAT THIS IS A VERY
VERY GOOD BILL AND I THINK THAT --
IT CLEARLY ADDRESSES A PROBLEM --
AND THE PROVIDE THE NECESSARY
REFORMS TO PREVENT THIS RACE TO
THE BOTTOM IS IS IS IS IS IS
WHAT WE'RE CONFRONTED WITH YOU
KNOW EVEN OUR DISADVANTAGED --
OUR COMMUNITIES ARE BEING TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF AT THE EXPENSE OF
EVERYONE ELSE SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR EFFORT I THINK IS A VERY
GOOD BILL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY BEFORE YOU MOVE ON IF YOU
DON'T MIND OR WHAT IS STILL WAS
A QUORUM SO WE CAN MOVE THIS
ALONG -- SECRETARY.
AGUIAR-CURRY HERE AGUIAR-CURRY
HERE LACKEY LACKEY HERE BLOOM.
BLOOM HERE BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH HERE RAMOS THREE
OF US ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVAS HERE VOEPEL
[inaudible]
VOEPEL HERE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR STEPS A
QUORUM -- ARE THERE ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
ENTERTAIN A MOTION ANYONE.
HAVE A MOTION.
A SECOND THAT [inaudible]
GOT IT.
I'LL SECOND THE BILL.
OTHER REJECTED CLOSE THANK YOU
FOR SOME MAY THINK THAT YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORK I REALLY READING A GREAT
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS AND MEMBERS
IN THE ANALYSIS IT POINTS OUT
THAT THIS ISSUE'S BEEN LOOKED AT
BY OUR STATE AUDITOR -- IT AS
WELL AS THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S TO EXAMINE THIS ISSUE
IN A NUMBER OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED HERE ON
THE COMMITTEE TODAY AND AND AND
THE LA -- MADE IT CLEAR IN THERE
THEN THEIR STATE AND THEY SAID
THAT THESE FINANCIAL INCENTIVES
DOES NOT RESULT IN ANY NET
BENEFIT. TO OUR BROADER ECONOMIC
REGION WITHIN OUR STATE.
THAT THAT WITH YOU LOCATED NO
CATION A OR B. OR C..
THAT IF THAT IS A THAT IF THE IF
THE COMPANIES HAVE THE ABILITY
TO MANIPULATE IT NO ONE WINS
THERE EXCEPT WE LOSE THOSE TAX
DOLLARS ABOUT A BILLION DOLLARS.
A YEAR SO I I I APPRECIATE THAT
THOUGHTFUL CONSIDERATION THIS
BILL'S GOTTEN BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
ALL THE WAY THROUGH -- IT'S NOT
MEANT TO BE IN OUR A. D. ISSUE
IT'S IT'S GOT SUPPORT FROM FROM
LABOR WHO RECOGNIZES THE LOSS OF
TAX DOLLARS THAT -- WE'RE
SUFFERING BY -- AND IT DOESN'T
DEAL WITH THE BIG PROBLEM BUT IT
SAYS LET'S STOP THE BLEEDING AND
THE LEAGUE OF CITIES THAT CAN
WORK ON THIS FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS AND IT.
AND WE'RE TOGETHER ON THIS WEEK
THIS IS A A SAFE SPACE TO SAY
LET'S NOT MAKE IT WORSE WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL THE
CITY'S -- EVEN THE DISADVANTAGE
WANTS TO TRY TO FIND A BETTER
PATH FORWARD BUT AT LEAST FOR
NOW LET'S NOT MAKE IT WORSE WHAT
WE HAVE MORE TO UNRAVEL IF
THERE'S ANY UNRAVELING TO BE
DONE.
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASTRONAUT.
THANK YOU FOR SENATOR I
APPRECIATE YOU HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH ME SO THAT I
COULD MAKE SURE THAT WE DIDN'T
HARM THOSE EXISTING CITIES THAT
ARE UNDER THIS -- BUT I DO THINK
WE NEED TO START WORKING ON
HAVING A PATH MOVING FORWARD AND
WITH THAT I WILL BE SUPPORTING
YOUR BILL THIS AFTERNOON THANK
YOU [inaudible]
SECTOR.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
REVENUE AND TAXATION
AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I LACKEY LACKEY NO
BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS THREE OF
US ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
OF HELL NO.
OKAY YOUR BUT YOUR BILLS ON CALL
AND HOPEFULLY WE GET THOSE OF
THE TO GET YOURSELF THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO THINK --
THE PEOPLE THAT CAME FROM PARIS
AND FRESNO TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
ARGUING OVER BEFORE I MOVE ON
WE'RE LIKE TO ENTERTAIN A MOTION
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR MISSED
WILL PRODUCE. FOR SEX.
PROMOTIONS.
OKAY.
A SECOND.
PROMOTION A SECOND MOTION FROM A
FOR HARPER AND WE HAVE ROBERT
RIVAS.
AGUIAR-CURRY -- I AGUIAR-CURRY I
LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS THREE OF
US ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE.
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I YEAH.
IT'S OUT OKAY I THINK.
WE OKAY ONE OF MY AUTHORS
DISAPPEARED SO.
OKAY THAT'S FINE -- WHAT IS HOLD
ON HERE FOR A MINUTE OR
?
TWO GOOD AFTERNOON THIS THE
SENATOR RUBIO WE ARE NOW ON ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB.
FOUR THIRTEEN AND A WELCOME
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB FOUR ONE THREE IT
DISTRICTS SPECIFIC BILL THAT
WOULD CONSOLIDATE.
DUPLICATIVE REPORTS AND MODIFY
THE ELECTIONS SCHEDULED FOR THE
SAME HERO BASS AND WATER QUALITY
AUTHORITY.
ASTLEY CITY COUNCIL ELECIONS
WERE HELD IN ODD NUMBER YEARS
AND THE AUTHORITY BOARD
ELECTIONS ARE HELD OR EVEN
NUMBER YEARS HOWEVER RECENT
CHANGES.
HAVE COST THE CITY AND MY
DISTRICT NOW TO HOLD THEIR
ELECTIONS IN EVEN NUMBERED YEARS
[inaudible]
EXCUSE ME.
THIS MAY CREATE A PROBLEM WITH
THE CANDIDATES SIMULTANEOUSLY
WRITING FOR THE CITY COUNCIL.
AND THE AUTHORITY BOARD WINS THE
AUTHORITY BUT LOSES THE CITY
COUNCIL ACTION HELLO TURKEY.
SO WHAT THIS BILL WOULD DO.
IT WOULD SOLVE THE PROBLEM BY
STARTING THE AUTHORITY'S BOARD
THE ELECTIONS WITH CITY COUNCIL
BOARDS.
SO ONE ELECTION HAPPENS AT ONE
TIME AND THEN THE OTHER THE
FOLLOWING YEAR.
THE BOARD DISCUSSED THIS CHANGES
WITH PUBLIC AT PUBLIC WORKSHOPS
IN HEARINGS AND UNANIMOUSLY
ADOPTEDA POSITION OF SUPPORT.
THERE AFTER HEARING OPPOSITION
HERE WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IS
RANDY SHOULDER MAN.
ASSISTANT EXECUTIVE DIRECTORAND
SENIOR ENGINEER FOR THE TAKE
YOUR BASE TO WATER QUALITY
THIRTY FOR YOU QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS --
THE WATER AUTHORITY IS A OVERSEE
THE GROUNDWATER BASIN WHICH HAS
A MAJOR CLEANUP GOING ON WE HAVE
THIRTY TWO ACTIVE TREATMENT
SYSTEMS.
THAT REQUIRE SOME REPORTING AND
WE DO A ANNUAL -- CLEAN UP.
REPORT PROGRAM THAT -- IS PUT
OUT EVERY YEAR THIS BILL HELPS
US CONSOLIDATE SOME THAT
REPORTING THAT'S REQUIRED --
INSTEAD OF REPORTING THIS OUT
THREE TIMES A YEAR WE CAN DO IT
ONCE A YEAR WITH THAT OUR GROUND
WATER REMEDIATION -- DESIGN
ANALYSIS AND SO THAT WOULD MAKE
MAKING MUCH MORE EFFICIENT FOR
OUR READERS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
ARE AGENCIES DOING THIS -- BE
MUCH APPRECIATED -- SO WITH THAT.
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL ARNOLD HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE THREE DOLLARS MUNICIPAL
WATER DISTRICT STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL WHICH WILL
SAVE MONEY FOR OUR LOCAL
AGENCIES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
IF ANY MILLION ON BEHALF THE SAN
GABRIEL VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IT SUPPORT THANK YOU
FOR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS GENESIS
TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA GROUNDWATER COALITION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS GAVE
ROMAN OURS ON BEHALF OF SAYING
YOUR VALLEY WATER COMPANY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THE OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
SING NON INDIAN OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT LET'S MOVE IT ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
BUT OUR MOTION AT THE LAW.
WELL I HAVE A MOTION FROM --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY NEVER
SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RIVAS.
NO NO QUESTION FIVE K. -- WITH
YEAH -- WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
RIGHT -- I'D LIKE TO SAY IS THAT
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES COMMONSENSE.
THIS MAKES SO MUCH SENSE SO --
OBVIOUS OR PUT SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING IT FORWARD AND HOPE TO
SAVE SOME MONEY FOR YOUR
CONSTITUENTS THANK YOU SO MUCH
REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER
TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY I HEY LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
RAMOS THREE OF US ROBERT RIVAS.
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
BILLS ON CALL AND WE'LL WAIT FOR
THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT NEXT BUT NOT LAST IS
NUMBER ONE FOR TODAY SB NINETY
NINE CENTER NIELSEN.
WELCOME SENATOR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE.
TO PRESENT TO YOU SB NINETY NINE
TODAY AND I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH US
AND WE WILL ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT
SUGGESTED.
AND I WOULD CERTAINLY LIKE TO
ADD THE CHAIR AS A PRINCE CO
AUTHOR OF THAT.
BE SUITABLE TO HER THE HONOR TO
BE A PRINCIPAL FOR A GOOD TEAM
ON THIS [inaudible]
ONE THIS.
LEGISLATION WILL ASSURE THAT
[inaudible]
AREAS.
COUNTIES THAT HAVE THESE SEVERE
FIRE.
LIKELY AREAS AND MANY OF OUR
ROLE DISTRICTS ARE SO PRO. ONE
OF THE DIFFICULTIES IS OFTEN.
THE INGRESS AND EGRESS. TO GET
FIRE FIGHTING EQUIPMENT IN TO
THE AREA.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY TO GET
PEOPLE OUT.
AND WHATEVER THE DISASTER IS AND
IT'S NOT JUST FIRES OF COURSE.
ONE OF THE AREAS THAT I'VE
REPRESENTED FOR A LONG TIME
PARADISE.
BUT MOST OF THE HISTORY ONLY HAD
ONE WROTE.
COMING DOWN THAT RIDGE.
OUT.
THE SECONDARY ROADS THEN FINALLY
WAS.
EFFECTED BUT THERE WAS DEFICIENT.
THERE WAS A TREMENDOUS PROBLEM.
WHEN THAT FIRE HIT?
YEAR AND A HALF PRIOR.
WHEN THE ORAL DAM SPILLWAY
FAILED?
NOT WITHSTANDING.
BROUGHT MORE ROADS AVAILABILITY.
EVACUATING THE HUNDRED EIGHTY
EIGHT THOUSAND PEOPLE.
THROUGH THREE COUNTIES.
WAS QUITE A PROBLEM.
SO WHAT THIS LEGISLATION DOES IS
[inaudible]
CREATE.
AN ALTERNATIVE THAT FOR THESE
AFFECTED AREAS.
THERE MUST BE TO EVACUATION
[inaudible]
WROTE [inaudible]
SECURED [inaudible]
AVAILABLE.
AND COMMUNICATED TO THE PUBLIC.
SO THEY KNOW [inaudible]
WHERE THIS [inaudible]
WILL BE.
AND THAT THEY CAN BE IN AN
ORDERLY MANNER.
MANY COUNTIES SINCE THESE
DISASTERS HAVE STEPPED UP THEIR
EVACUATION PLANTS.
THE CENTERS WHERE THEY WILL
ACCUMULATE PEOPLE AND SORT OUT.
CARS AND TRAFFIC.
BUT WE STILL ABSOLUTELY HAVE GOT
TO HAVE.
THE EXIT ROUTES.
AND THIS WILL SET FORTH.
A PLAN FOR THAT [inaudible] ONE
VERY PERSONAL EXAMPLE OF THIS.
THE FELLOW WHO IS A FRIEND OF
MINE AND USED TO WORK FOR ME WAS
THE CEO OF BUTTE COUNTY FOR MANY
YEARS LIVED UP IN THE GAME.
AND I WAS ON THE PHONE WITH HIM.
HIS WIFE WAS EVACUATED HE WAS
DOWN IN THE VALLEY AND SHE WAS
AT THEIR HOME.
TRYING TO GET OUT.
SHE WAS USING.
THE SKY WAY WHICH IS THE MAIN
ROUTE AND SHE SAID OH MY GOD
THERE'S FIRE. TO MY RIGHT.
COMING RIGHT UP THE ROAD NOW
THERE IS THE SECOND EXIT ROUTE
THAT HAS JUST BEEN RE ESTABLISH
A FEW YEARS AGO.
HE SAID TURN AROUND HONEY AND GO
THE OTHER WAY.
WHICH SHE DID.
SHE HAD NO MORE THAN TURNED
AROUND AND SHE SAID WELL I GOT
THE FIRES ON BOTH SIDES OF ME
NOW.
WELL SHE AND QUITE A FEW OTHERS
GOT OUT.
BUT WHAT WOULD HAVE BEEN AT THAT
SECONDARY ROUTE NOT BEEN
AVAILABLE.
NOR HAD THE SKY WAY BEEN
IMPROVED.
SO THAT MORE PEOPLE COULD ACTION.
AND THAT VERY CONGESTED AREA
AGAIN THESE ARE.
PROBLEMS THAT WE FACE ALL OVER.
AND SUCH CATASTROPHES WE'RE
GOING TO GO GET TO DATE WILL
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN.
WE MUST BE READY AND THIS
LEGISLATION GIVES.
AN ALTERNATE ROUTE.
THAT WOULD SAY BLACKS I WOULD.
ASKYOUR INDULGENCE.
AND YOUR AYE BOAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OTHER OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
AS LONG AS A SAY HOW DARE YOU IF
YOU POSE.
ANY QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY I NEED A MOTION ON THE
TABLE.
OKAY -- MOTION.
FROM A ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RIVAS --
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I WOULD
ASK AN AYE VOTE RESPECTFULLY AND
I THANK YOU FOR YOUR OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT THE BILL -- WELL
OBVIOUSLY I'M GOING TO SUPPORT
THIS BUT YOU KNOW AFTER YOU HAD
THIS BILL WAY AND WATCHING THE
TRAFFIC ON TELEVISION TRYING TO
GET OUT OF THERE -- SCARED THE
HECK OUT OF ME AND NOT LESS
THOSE OF US WHO LIVE IN THOSE
RURAL AREAS WE KIND OF KNOW
WHERE THIS MIGHT BE SOME SIDE
COUNTY ROADS BUT NOT EVERYBODY
KNOWS THOSE.
NO AND THE SAME OF PARADISE YOU
KNOW THE WAY ON THE SKY WAY I'VE
BEEN UP THERE NUMEROUS TIMES BUT
I DON'T I DON'T KNOW THAT I KNEW
THE SECOND.
ROUTE TO GET OUT OF THERE IF I
WAS STUCK IN THAT.
SO I THINK THE IMPORTANCE OF
THIS BILL IS THAT WE ARE SENDING
OUT A MESSAGE TO EVERYBODY THIS
IS REALLY IMPORTANT.
YOU KNOW I'VE LIVED THROUGH THIS
YES AND UNTIL YOU LIVE THROUGH
IT YOU DON'T REALLY GET IT
SOMETIMES AND SO I APPRECIATE
YOUR BRINGING THIS FORWARD IN A
YOU KNOW I WANT TO BE A CO
AUTHOR AS IT IS SAID BEFORE BUT
I REALLY APPRECIATE YOU BRING
THIS FORD.
SENATOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN.
WITH THAT [inaudible]
SECRETARY.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS AGUIAR-CURRY.
AGUIAR-CURRY AYE LACKEY AYE
LACKEY AYE BLOOM.
BURNER **** BATH [inaudible]
RAMOS THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIDE ROBERT RIVAS
ROBERT RIVERSIDE VOEPEL.
THE BILL.
STILL NEEDS ONE WE HAVE -- WILL
PUT OUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MAKE IT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I WILL TRY TO CALL OUT FOR
MEMBERS TO COME BACK IN THERE.
I CLOSELY COMES [inaudible]
TO EVERY.
THE RED WE HAVE A OF BILLS ON
CALL -- REJECT FOR FIRST WILL BE
ITEM NUMBER ONE SB NINETY NINE
NIELSEN CURRENT VOTERS
[inaudible]
FOUR ZERO BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH -- HER
ABOUT THAT I RAMOS [inaudible]
VOEPEL.
BILLS OUT.
SIX ZERO ITEM NUMBER NINE SP
FOUR THIRTEEN RUBIO HURT VOTE IS
[inaudible]
THREE TWO BLOOM.
BLOOM I BOERNER HORVATH.
BOERNER HORVATH I RAMOS THREE OF
US.
THREE OF US FIVE VOEPEL.
BILLS OUT -- SIX ZERO ITEM
NUMBER TEN SB.
FIVE THIRTY ONE BLASIER HER VOTE
IS [inaudible]
THREE TO BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE RAMOS THREE OF US
THREE OF US SIGH.
BILLS OUT.
FIVE TWO I CAN THINK HOW UNDER
WE HAVE OUT ON THIS -- AS A
MATTER.
OF TOUCHES.
MR ROOM.
CONSENT CALENDAR.
OUT ON NO WE WE DID THAT HUMAN
OUT ON THEY CAN CHECK OUT.
BUT WE'RE GOING TO GET IT WE
JUST THINK IT WAS REFER.
ACTUALLY MAYBE SHE SAID
[inaudible]
JUST CHECKING.
YOU DID YOU DID YOUR GOOD.
I GET DIFFERENT [inaudible]
UNSHACKLED.
THE PHOTO.
ITEM NUMBER WHEN SENATE BILL
NINETY NINE NIELSEN RAMOS VOEPEL.
HI VOEPEL I CONSENT CALENDAR
BLOOM.
I RAMOS THREE OF US.
THREE OF US SIDE -- ITEM NUMBER
NINE SAID ABOUT FOUR THIRTEEN
RUBIO.
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I AND THIS IS
[inaudible]
FOR NOW.
WE'RE MISSING REMARKS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
YEAH I GET.
WHEN AWAY FROM IT FOR ONE OF OUR?
MEMBERS IT'S PROBABLY DOING A
BILL
.
YOU HAVE A CIRCULAR TO BE IN TWO
PLACES AT IT WILL GIVE ME ONLY A
FOR THINGS OF A ITEM NUMBER WHEN
THE SENATE BILL NINETY NINE
NIELSEN.
RAMOS.
RAMOS HI.
FINAL VOTE ON IT IS.
EIGHT ZERO CONSENT CALENDAR
RAMOS.
RAMESSIDE CONSENT.
THE FINAL VOTE ON THAT IS.
EIGHT ZERO ITEM NUMBER NINE
SENATE BILL FOR THIRTEEN RUBIO
FROM US.
RAMESSIDE FINAL VOTE IS.
EIGHT ZERO ITEM TEN SENATE BILL
FIVE THREE WHEN GLAZER RAMOS.
RAMOS HI FINAL VOTE ON THAT IS.
SIX TWO THANK YOU AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IS ADJOURNED